[Musique]
elle s'appelle li ji demian et elle
restera dans l'histoire comme la
première vainqueur du paris-roubaix
version féminine et qui s'est couru pour
la toute première fois donc aujourd'hui
la britannique a attaqué assez tôt sur
l'un des secteurs pavés qui rendent la
course mythique est si difficile de
nombreuses chutes ont d'ailleurs eu lieu
dans cette zone vous allez le voir et
puis l'idi n'a plus été rattrapé par la
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle s'est dite très émue d'entrée ainsi
dans l'histoire écoutez bien elle
remporte la somme de 1500 euros pour
cette victoire soit 20 fois moins que le
vainqueur masculin qui gagnera demain
trente mille euros ça me fait de la
peine
je vis pas très bien que ça va aller ça
va passer
année après année
chino apprend comment se comporter face
aux squales
il teste ses limites quitte à se faire
quelques frayeurs
[Musique]
un apprentissage qui a laissé des traces
une mini caméra perdue dans les
montagnes du wyoming a été retrouvé est
allumé par un ours sur cette vidéo
filmée par l'animal donc on le voit très
intriguée par l'objet c'est dylan un
habitant du coin qui est tombé par
hasard sur l'appareil lors d'une sortie
la batterie était alors à plat c'est en
la rechargeant qu'il a découverts ces
quatre minutes trente de la vie d'un
ours avant de les partager sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est quoi la principale qualité d'un
nourrisseur
déjà il faut être un très bon plongeur
avec beaucoup d'expérience et il faut
avoir déjà plongé avec ces requins
lettre au minimum 200 fois et surtout il
faut une bonne grosse pertes des banques
vous avez des glandes surrénales qui
sont le double de celle de nous de deux
mois oui ça c'est une rigolade avec
commente en fait vous savez que vous
marchez avec un certain nombre de
corticoïdes d'amis capable de vous
donner l'énergie et le fait que le fait
de dormir très peu et de me passionner
pour plein de choses a entraîné un
certain nombre de démarches médicales
qui monte a pris ce que j'avais des
glandes surrénales très importante
j'aurais préféré que ce soit d'autre
mais celle est sûre et non ce charmant
tout aime bien comme ça tu es content
[Rires]
je pars du principe où il vaut mieux
bien c'est mais tout reste un parce que
comme personne ne m'aime budget de mai
mais pour les autres 1 marie-anne chazel
vous voyez le jour sous le ciel de cap
en 1951 mais c'est un autre ciel qui
ponctuent cette année là celui de notre
belle capitale une dame à l'intermarché
ou un supermarché là vous avez quand
vous achetez les croquettes des chats et
où elle vient vous voir au départ naquit
nerfs est ce qu'on peut faire un seul
fil du bon nombre est bien madame je
suis pas maquillée là aujourd'hui là je
suis moche elle me fait on sait pas
grave moi aussi je suis moche je dis oui
mais vous vous avez l'habitude
nos téléspectateurs adorent cette
rubrique les années tubes parfois les
invités à prévoir c'est vrai qu'on est
obligé de rapts et évanescence pas
élégante du tout
ces 20 minutes je suis très déçu
et à mort
vous avez raison ça ce serait pire toute
la journée ils sont nombreux à être
venus déposer des fleurs devant son
hôtel particulier
c'est ici à paris que bernard tapie a
livré son dernier combat contre le
cancer qui le rongeait depuis quatre ans
avec lui c'est toute une époque qui s'en
va
[Musique]
nous sommes en avril 1983
ce soir là la télévision diffuse pour la
première fois un portrait de bernard
tapie
on y présente un homme d'affaires pesant
800 millions de francs et qui affiche sa
réussite flamboyante et cela de façon
totalement décomplexée j'ai fait les
comptes à le sondage mois qui vient de
tomber jadot 9 mélenchon 9 roussel 1,5
hidalgo 5,5 montebourg 1 5 26% vous
faites 26% là vous y serez au deuxième
tour vous un autre où anne hidalgo ou
jadot s'est pas au tout se ranger
derrière yannick jadot anne hidalgo à
mon avis elle a pas le pouvoir pour
l'instant de le faire ou rouen prend en
premier pourquoi pas mais entendez-vous
bon sens le bon dieu si vraiment vous
voulez que les gens aient une meilleure
fiche parle pas de moi moi j'ai une
belle vie mais moi j'assume je suis un
vrai capitaliste qui vit comme un
capitaliste
moi j'ai le droit au profit je me le
donne ce droit ça veut dire que j'ai le
droit d'avoir un jet je l' ai gagnée
et à cette époque cette façon d'être
fier de gagner de l'argent et de le
revendiquer fait l'effet d'une bombe
qu'est ce que la vie vous a appris
finalement que l'expérience est une
bougie qui n'a cure que celui qui la
porte
oui
c'est la troisième fois vous êtes
candidat à la présidentielle ça fait
quarante trois ans vous êtes dans la
politique vous avez été ministre député
député européen sénateur vous vous dites
pas un moment d'accès pour quelqu'un
d'autre wahou non je
sais ce qu'il fallait pas dire
être énervé pas mais je sais pas je ne
vais pas vous fait rire c'est plutôt
différents crédits
coc
que j'existe
le premier sélectionné pas mal c'est
pour vérifier par un geste simple notre
détermination face à une décision qu'on
vient de prendre à nous montrer et vous
nous expliquer pourquoi alors vous
parlez de ce geste là oui parce que
celui-là n'est
[Rires]
jamais
seul le jour où vous aurez une émission
qui fait autant de boîtes noires aux
élections je viendrai me démentir
allez-y
vous le prenez pas mal ce que je n'avais
aucune mauvaise attends je sais pas moi
qui le prend mal on va me mettre c'est
pas le lieu mais vous avez blessé
beaucoup de temps avec son france 2 on
va passer c'est pas parce que vous avez
une grande gueule et vous crier fort que
vous arrivez au lit
la seule différence c'est que c'est pas
parce que vous affirmez fort quelque
chose que ce que vous dites est vrai
parce que vous dites n'importe quoi ici
il était le boss depuis ce matin bernard
tapie trône devant sa maison de coeur le
stade vélodrome les supporters de
l'olympique de marseille n'ont jamais
oublié leur ancien président je me
remémore les images d'amendements dans
ma tête lâcher de ballons quand mon père
m'emmenait au stade ça c'est tout lui de
feu d'artifice c'est lui donc les gros
jouet à des wadden les patins les
bolides du tout donc c'est tout lui le
record de l'atlantique
une victoire de la champion's league le
tour de france chanteurs acteurs
et puis quelques envers preuve beaucoup
dans merde
mais bon ok par bouffer ça valait le
détour
franchement